and i wouldn't say that out loud because
like i like my job and they want to be
fired i don't even remember how i
cleaned that up
i blocked it out because it was so gross
you just pelted your grandma with a
bunch of adult toys like how do you feel
so one day i had a customer come in and
she seemed pretty cool she was fun
she was chewing on a big wad of bubble
gum
that big i'm not even kidding i was
helping her out she tried on at least 30
to 40 pieces of clothing
and then i rang her up at the end
because that's what you're supposed to
do and of course i had to go back to the
fitting room after to clean up
i opened up the fitting room and the
clothes were just all over the floor
not even one piece of clothing was hung
up they were all over the floor
there were shoe prints on some of the
pieces of clothing there was foundation
all over some of the pieces of clothing
it was a disaster so i clean those up
and i start hanging them up in the
fitting room itself
and then i look at the ground again and
i notice that big
wad of bubble gum just stuck to the
floor
surrounded and spit
i worked in the scow boutique and i was
like the go-to girl for pageant stuff
because
in total i probably competed for like 10
years that's like 50 plus pageants
but i was also like not the
stereotypical
pageant girl i didn't look like a barbie
unless i was all dolled up
when we would work in the store you know
we would wear all black
and be pretty modest one day this young
woman walks in
maybe like five years older than me and
she tells us that she's competing in
miss florida usa pageant it was going to
be a fun experience though i thought
i have never seen someone look so far
down their nose at me
and i'm not sure so it takes a lot a lot
to look down your nose at me i found out
through talking with her that this was
going to be her first big pageant
for some reason she just felt like she
just knew everything i'm trying to help
pick
dresses for her and everything i picked
there's a problem
it started to become less about the
actual clothing and more about
me and my taste and anything i picked
wouldn't be good enough
the attitude was reeking from a mile
away but my boss pulled me over at one
point and she's like hey
uh wrap it up she needs to go she ended
up walking out not getting anything
because she just
i know she just didn't want to work with
me flash forward two weeks later
the reigning miss florida usa is having
a really big party
i walk over to the rainy miss florida
usa and like oh my gosh she's like i
don't know i should hug
i look over and the city queen
local title holder that had been so
shady and so rude
and so obnoxious to little me is over
there with her mouth on the floor
hello she also didn't realize i was the
reigning ijm miss florida teen
but the part that got like a little bit
weird because then she like proceeded to
add me on every social media platform i
was on
so back in high school i used to work
for uh a
very special erotic gift store
that's at a lot of malls if you know you
know
what y'all don't know is everything bad
that happens at the mall
happens on the weekend this particular
weekend i was covering a shift we were
having
a sale on adult toys that weekend i was
working at the cash register
as normal one girl came in i think she
was about 21 years old and she was with
her grandmother
and she's like can you help me pick out
a vibrator because she didn't want her
grandma to know
i wanted to know she like needed me to
be like a decoy or something which i was
willing to do
and she's like oh but she's blind so
it's fine i was like
okay so why are you concerned she
started looking around you know she's
like
going through all the little packages
and she spots like
honestly like a really big one like
right at the top
oh okay i was like you know i'll go get
a ladder i'll be right back and she's
like oh that's not necessary
she starts climbing the adult toys wall
like she's rock climbing or something
she kicks
this shelf that's like near the very top
and tell me why they like come crashing
down
and like pelting the grandma and i was
just like
grandma reaches on the ground with her
blind self
and grabs one of the adult toys he
basically like
turned it on like no hesitation like
just turned it on and started like
the girl tried to play it off she was
like oh hey we're in an electronic store
you know you're gonna break something
and the grandma's like don't lie to me i
know what this is mean your grandfather
used to use these when he was alive
i'll take this one you know she's a
little freak
we love that the girl honestly looks
like she wanted to puke or faint
at that point and i was just like girl
i'm just
i'm just here for my check i
worked in a mom-and-pop boutique it was
like a pretty small but
semi-luxurious kind of store we had some
really cool stuff
literally in these fake gucci sunglasses
this woman walks in and says i've
arrived
and she was like yes i want to try on
all these dresses
great get that bag get that commission
so we got 10 dresses for her and we gave
it to her to try on
after coming out in the first dress she
was like hey can you take a picture from
me real quick
and then that one picture became two
pictures which became three pictures
which became a 30 minute photo shoot for
her
in the dressing room i asked her hey do
you want to buy any of the dresses and
she goes
um can i check the jewelry instead i
knew what she was doing at this point so
i talked to my manager
he came down and he was like sorry miss
mourinho asked you to leave she threw a
hissy fit
she was upset she was like this is
horrible i hate this establishment
your workers suck so i woke up the next
morning and i checked my social medias
always
here tagged is the same girl captioned
wow i love this great sponsorship
everyone treats me like a queen
and i love it here you are treating me
and my manager like crap
and then hear you on social media
promoting love and unity
and happiness but you know what it's
okay because her follower to like ratio
was absolutely horrible it seemed like
she had bots so
like at the end of the day retail
workers are just like anyone else and
they deserve at least
respect there are a lot of customers who
do forget that retail workers are also
just human beings
working we're all just trying to make a
living out here so why be rude and
condescending and look down on someone
who's just trying to earn their key
y'all need to start being nicer to these
people because they
are doing a service for y'all and y'all
need to be rude
[Music]
[Applause]
you